[Music]
for me
I'm damned if I do give a damn what
people say Taylor Swift puts her fans in
a lavender Haze I love it the singer's
Midnight's era goes on as she drops the
video for lavender Hayes and as she
describes it it's a 70s fever dream that
follows her through purple pools hazy
living room dance parties and Fields of
lavender in her own house and it fits
perfectly with the meaning of the song
which Tay confirmed is inspired by her
romance with Joe alwin
[Music]
and I happened upon the phrase lavender
Hayes when I was watching Mad Men look
at you
you're in the lavender Haze like if you
were in the lavender Haze then that
meant that you were in that
all-encompassing love glow and I thought
that was really beautiful I guess
theoretically when you're in the
lavender Haze you'll do anything to stay
there
um and not let people bring you down off
of that cloud like my relationship for
six years we've had to dodge weird
rumors tabloid stuff and we just ignore
it and the entire music video seems to
be a tribute to her long time love I
don't mind it here are the Easter eggs
to prove why the biggest one Joe's
astrological sign Pisces is everywhere
with fish symbols all over the video
they're bringing up my history
[Music]
I just lost
and Taylor also plays off the
astrological thing a little bit more on
a vinyl that says Mastermind there are
two constellations Sagittarius and
Pisces tase star sign along his and
Mastermind is another song from
midnights which has lyrics about stars
aligning Once Upon a Time
[Music]
you and I ended up in the same room at
the same time
it's very hard to give general advice
when it comes to love I think the reason
why we turn to music is because
um you know we can somehow apply that
song to what we're going through in our
life and um I just feel very honored to
be that music that some people turn to
aside from her focus on Joe fans seem to
think Tay's once again dropping a hint
about her next re-release speak now and
yes we're bringing back the fishies see
the koi behind her well back during her
speak now era Taylor had a guitar with
the exact fish on it as far as my
musical Direction goes I would always
like to keep people on their toes in
that regard I think that's the best way
to be exciting
foreign